[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so i have a lot of interesting news
for you guys i'm so excited to come back
to you with a new sony film simulation
and this time is going to be a high
fidelity copy from fujifilm atari film
simulation first i want to make a short
introduction to the chapters and what
i'll be talking about in this video i'll
start with a comparison between the two
cameras to see the main differences
between fuji and sony next i will reveal
the settings for the profile and how to
set it up in the camera also how to
shoot it in terms of
exposure of temperature and color filter
lastly i'll show you
some raw footage from the camera and how
it was created using the eight
millimeter home film power grade from
davinci and how you can use this slot to
create your own footage also super
interesting i created a sony film
simulation forum on my website so if you
want to find out more details about that
just stick till the end and let's get
started so the sony alternate film
simulation is an amazing profile with
beautiful gradations and colors giving a
great look out of the camera but that
doesn't mean you can upgrade it quite on
the contrary this video is color graded
using the 8 millimeter home fill print
but later in the video i'll show you
some sample footage straight from the
camera so you can make your own decision
whether this profile is for you or not
this profile is about 90 to 95 identical
to the fujifilm with slight differences
to be as accurate as possible
temperature has been set with the help
of a great card on both cameras and shot
at the same time
if we look at the two sample footage
between the color checker first thing
that we notice is the difference in the
contrast sony is based on helgi gamma
and has soft creamy gradations while
fuji has an overall flat look with
crunchy shadows this characteristic will
be very subjective to every person and
neither is better or worse on a sony the
shadows have a slight magenta tint while
fuji has a green one as for color i want
to mention this footage was shot before
final adjustments after comparing the
footage i made some slight modifications
in the color depth to bring them closer
together so actually you will get more
accurate reproduction than in the sample
shown in this video because i was just
too lazy to reshoot the comparison i'll
slowly drag the slider so you can pause
and see for yourself the slight
differences as you can see the blue and
the yellows seem a little bit darker in
this comparison so after checking the
footage i went back into the profile and
brought up the luma values for the
selected colors overall greens are a
little bit more saturated on the sony
and with warmer tones while fuji greens
are more desaturated and leaning towards
cyan or blue sony has more saturated
yellows than the fuji while reds are
more dissaturated and have a tendency
towards orange i feel like sony usually
has warmer color tones compared to other
camera manufacturers so to properly
match the two i recommend shooting 200
to 500 kelvin below normal settings for
example if daylight is usually 5500
kelvin as a rule of thumb we're going to
set the camera between 5300 or 5000
kelvin to bring down the colors towards
the colder tonalities this way you will
shift the greens closer to cyan and red
closer to pink
overall i would say this profile is
about 90 to 95 percent identical to the
fuji which is a really good match
between the two cameras if you ask me
these are really subtle differences and
most people won't even notice at the
first side so now you can match the two
straight out of the camera with minimal
effort
now that we saw how it looks compared to
the fuji let's set it up i'll walk you
through this on sony cameras usually at
the top right corner there's a custom
tube button which is assigned to picture
profiles if not you will have to dig
into the menu and find it on my camera
is at page 12 at the photo icon
so enter the menu and here you can see
all 10 picture profiles if you have a7s3
you will have 11 picture profiles so
you're a lucky one choose one and hit
right to go even deeper into the menus
from here all we have to do is to
replace the settings as shown on the
screen these are the settings for the
sony alternate film simulation picture
profile also with suggested kelvin and
color filter adjustments
remember pressing the menu button will
take you back one page so after you've
finished setting up the profile just hit
ok and half press the shutter to exit
the menu next we will set a kelvin and
color filter i've set this function to
the joystick for fast access for this
video i tested a variation of kelvin
values between four thousand and six
thousand six hundred kelvin and
different color filter options most
preferred was at 4 300 kelvin with color
filter at m2 a3 also another important
detail worth mentioning i always shoot
srgb in favor of adobe rgb
choosing one over another will influence
how the camera renders colors and i
prefer srgb you can change that from the
menu obviously these settings can be
tweaked and you can shoot a different
kelvin or make use of the color filter
to exaggerate different tones and shades
so don't be afraid to play around
pushing the temperature towards 4 500
kelvin will shift the greens which as
you can see results into nice bluish
tones in the grass
like i mentioned before this footage was
color graded to push it even closer to
film look let me show you how it looks
straight out of the camera and how to
use the eight millimeter home film print
to grade your own footage
so this is the image before the power
grade and after the eight millimeter
home fill
this film print is a drag and drop
solution and it comes in multiple
flavors as you can see adjustments are
separated individually and each node is
labeled so it's easier to find the one
that you need and edit or disable it
compared to classical luts power grades
offer you the full control over the
grade which means you can enter each
node to see what i've done and modify if
needed but for this video all i did is
to adjust the contrast and lower the
saturation
you can find this great on my website
now let's check the raw footage this is
straight from the camera and like i said
i was testing the colors so some footage
might look funkier than it should in
some cases i pushed the color filter too
close to magenta and it shifted the
color of the sky towards pink which is
not quite the look i was going for but
when i shot daytime at 4 500 or 5300
kelvin
it rendered very natural and pleasing
colors
i'm very surprised of how well the
greens are looking
dynamic range is amazing with super nice
gradations between highlights mid tones
and shadows
skin tone is perfect and i wouldn't
expect glass from heel g3 gamma
[Music]
compared to s-log helg base iso starts
from 100 or 125 and has very little
noise if you expose them well and
require no grading if you don't plan on
post processing
as for exposure elgi is a hybrid log
gamma and with log in general you want
to expose to the right otherwise it will
be noisier than other profiles for
example cine1 which is probably the best
camera for low light but as long as you
have a fair amount of light i find it
okay to underexpose by half a stop or
even one stop but usually i would expose
at zero exposure or plus one
again it depends on your setup so you
will have to check the image assess and
decide for yourself if it's too noisy or
not okay don't leave yet i have some
exciting news for you just created a
forum on my website where we can all
come together to share custom film
recipes sample photos and just connect
with each other i think being part of a
community is just super cool so i would
like to meet all of you people there why
not join in another reason to join is
that i will be posting all the
experimental film simulation that i'm
currently working on before posting on
youtube and you will be updated of these
profiles before the video is out some of
the film profiles i'm working on at the
moment are classic chrome and kodachrome
64. i already posted some sample
pictures of the kodachrome and this
profile is super good one more thing i
started a hashtag called sony film
simulation so we can all use it every
time we post on social media using these
film profiles so go check the forum and
join in why not you can follow me on
instagram for personal projects or
follow our studio page for some
commercial work and i think that's it
for today
go out experiment have fun and see you
next time